The third and final movie in the To All The
Boys trilogy is finally here and it's filled
with incredible details from cheeky Kitty
call-backs and sweet treat easter eggs to
secret cameos.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
today I'm revealing all the hidden adorable
references you missed in Always and Forever.
Of course, spoilers ahead if you haven't seen
it yet.
The movie kicks off with Lara Jean writing
to Peter from Seoul in a café that looks
like it's ripped straight from the pages of
a comic book.
The amazing thing is that this isn't a set
but a real-life coffee shop in Seoul that's
been deliberately painted all white with black
outlines to create the illusion that you're
in a 2D cartoon.
Named after its street number, the café is
an incredibly popular location, especially
for posting on Instagram.
And the way it's used in the movie, along
with some of the film's comic-book-style transitions,
really reminded me of A-Ha's video for Take
On Me, which feels especially fitting given
LJ's love of 80s pop culture.
And another cute detail in the Korean café
scene is that the postcard that Lara Jean
writes to Peter has the words Seoulmates on
the front,
pointing to the fact that even though they
are already thousands of miles apart, LJ and
PK are still destined to be together.
"I love you, Peter.
Always and forever."
"Like a lingering fart.
Or nay, a bruise that never heals."
During Lara Jean's make-believe montage of
her future life with Peter after she imagines
getting into Stanford, she sees herself signing
a book she's written called "Whoa, Whoa, Whoa".
This is a funny nod to Peter's catchphrase
from the first movie.
"Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Whoa, whoa.
Hey, hey, hey.
Whoa, whoa, whoa..."
Although fans didn't get any "whoa, whoa,
whoas" in the second film, this moment in
the new movie is a little tribute to the huge
sensation and meme those words from Peter
became after the success of the first film.
Another image we see in LJ's imagined future
is her and Peter painting their home together.
As LJ watches on, Peter paints a big blue
heart with their initials in the middle, a
moment which reminded me of how LJ painted
a blue heart on a lantern after their first
real date in the second movie.
And those blue hearts in both films fit perfectly
with the trilogy's colour palette which relies
heavily on cyans,
as well as magentas and yellows as we can
see from the character's clothes, as well
as the films' sets, props, and cinematography.
And those signature colours, magenta, cyan
and yellow, are the same ones that the filmmakers
used to light the Empire State Building for
the New York rooftop party scene.
When Peter surprises the Coveys after they
get back from Korea, Kitty compliments him
on his "Welcome Home" sign.
"Your spatial planning could use work, but
I appreciate the glitter."
Which is a nice nod to this moment in the
second movie where Kitty used glitter for
the Valentine's card she secretly sent to
Mrs Rothschild on behalf of her dad.
"Dad's not a glitter type of guy."
"Nor were you a Peter Kavinsky kinda girl
till I sprinkled some glitter on it."
Genevieve complimenting Lara Jean's footwear
in "Always and Forever"..
"Oh, my God, cute shoes.
I like those."
..is a call-back to how Gen commented sarcastically
on LJ's boots in the first movie
"Cute boots.
Thank you so much for your service."
Notice how Lara Jean and Genevieve's position
in the hallway has been switched around this
time making this moment a mirror of the original
scene
and showing how they are both back to being
friends now rather than the antagonists they
were at the start of the first film.
Author Jenny Han's cameo in each of the movies
has become a tradition, and in Always and
Forever she makes a brief appearance in the
flashback scene of LJ and PK's meet-cute.
Han plays Principal Cho who calls Lara Jean
on stage to receive an attendance award.
According to the filmmakers, her appearances
– as a middle school principal in the first
and third movies, and as Adler High's vice
principal in the second movie
– give her character a mini career arc across
the trilogy.
By the way, the same crying girl that Jenny
Han was comforting on Valentine's Day in P.S.
I Still Love You, has a much happier moment
in Always and Forever when she's the recipient
of a musical promposal.
"Molly Marshall, will you go to prom with
me?"
"Yes, of course.
Yes!"
When LJ organises a "perfect" date with Peter,
she takes some inspiration from the classic
Coen Brothers' crime-comedy The Big Lebowski
and plans an evening at a local bowling alley,
where she sets their table with some tasty
treats for them to eat, including the same
kind of fruit turnovers she made for Peter
as a Valentine's Day gift in the second movie.
When Lara Jean is planning the perfect date,
she compiles a list of some of Peter's favourite
films for ideas.
It's mostly made up of action movies like
"Fast and Furious" but an interesting one
is "X-Men: Apocalypse", because that's the
film in which Lana Condor made her acting
debut as the mutant Jubilee.
"This is Scott.
He's new here too."
And this might be a little stretch, but the
movie "This Is The End" has been crossed out,
perhaps foreshadowing that although "Always
and Forever" is the final movie in the series,
this won't be the end of LJ and PK's story
as they choose to stay together at university
despite the many miles between them.
Oh, and Doctor Sleep appears on the list as
the director of the second and third To All
The Boys films, Michael Fimognari, was the
cinematographer on that movie.
Butterflies keep cropping in the new film,
from the poster in Lara Jean's English classroom,
to various knick-knacks in her bedroom, to
the ones on lockers at school.
Culturally, butterflies are often symbols
of transformation, freedom, and new beginnings,
all themes that are crucial in the final film
as Lara Jean is on the verge of a new life,
making big decisions that will take her from
her final days as a school girl to her new
future as a university student.
Which is why we also see a large butterfly
poster, as well as a 'follow your heart' poster,
in Margot's college room in Scotland, as she's
already making her own life for herself, and
encourages LJ to do the same.
As well as butterflies pointing to the theme
of change in LJ's life, the film is full of
posters that foreshadow her decision to choose
New York University over Berkeley.
Even before LJ knows that she's been accepted
to NYU, at school there are New York posters
with the Statue of Liberty all around Peter.
And as they all hand in their permission slips
for the east-coast trip, we see posters including
one with the words 'How Far Will You Go?',
a drawing of a woman with a question mark
over her signalling how LJ will question her
decision about university,
and a poster of another woman with the words
'Own Your Story', which feels especially fitting
because as LJ's dad tells her later:
"Listen Lara Jean, you got to stay true to
yourself;
you can't save this relationship by not growing."
Likewise, when LJ's struggling to decide whether
she should follow her desire to go to NYU,
and asks Gen whether she should go,
she's standing next to posters that feature
the Statue of Liberty, the words 'Do what
you love', and 'You are stronger than you
think'!
The fabric box that Lara Jean fills with memories
of their relationship and gives to Peter is
actually the same box that held LJ's letters
to all the boys she'd loved before,
which gives it extra emotional value because
it was instrumental in how LJ and Peter's
relationship began.
After Lara Jean accidentally texts Peter that
she got into Stanford, to celebrate he turns
up outside her house recreating the iconic
scene from "Say Anything",
the 80s rom com where the male lead holds
up a boombox to prove his love.
"There's this great scene with John Cusack,
and he sits underneath the window.
And he holds up a boombox..
Okay!"
Lara Jean's love of classic 80s movies has
been a hallmark of her story in this trilogy,
from her recreating the opening scene of "Adventures
in Babysitting" at the beginning of P.S.
I Still Love You,
to the rule she made in the first movie that
Peter could put his hand in her back pocket,
an idea taken from the opening scene of "Sixteen
Candles".
And she acknowledges this in her closing monologue
of this movie.
"My whole life..
I've wanted the kind of love you see in the
movies.
Boombox over the head, hand in the back pocket
of your jeans kind of love."
At the beginning of the movie, we see Lara
Jean reading Pride and Prejudice, and the
film also draws attention to her packing the
classic novel for her trip to New York.
As a romantic comedy of manners, it's clear
why Pride and Prejudice would appeal to LJ,
but I think the book is also alluding to how
she and Peter both grow and mature in their
relationship throughout the final film, and
trilogy as a whole,
similar to how the main protagonists in Jane
Austen's novel work to overcome their flaws
to ultimately achieve a happy romantic union.
"Do you dance, Mr Darcy?"
"Not if I can help it."
"Do you dance, Mr. Kavinsky?"
"Mm.
Not if I can help it."
And the repeated Pride and Prejudice references
may also be a little nod to the third book
in Jenny Han's trilogy where LJ creates a
mood board featuring the Pride & Prejudice
movie for her dad and Trina's wedding.
Oh, and let's not forget that LJ's sister
Kitty, aka Katherine..
"I'm Katherine.
That was weird, that's not my name.
Kitty.
Well, Katherine's kind of my name, but people
don't call me that.
Call me Kitty.
You can call me whatever."
shares her name with one of the characters
in Jane Austen's famous novel.
Lara Jean's love of Harry Potter in the original
books was touched upon in the second movie
in a flashback scene where she's reading The
Prisoner of Azkaban together with John Ambrose,
and Harry Potter comes up again in the third
film when it turns out that LJ's sister Kitty
is also a huge Potter-head, and she's outraged
to discover her Korean boyfriend [Dae] hates
it.
He said, and I quote, "that it's so dumb."
How am I supposed to be in a relationship
with someone who thinks the greatest literary
achievement of our time is dumb?
And if you want to discover all the easter
eggs and incredible details you missed in
P.S.
I Still Love You as well, tap here to watch
that video or follow the link in the video
description.
So, what did you think of Always and Forever?
Did you like the ending and were there any
other interesting details you noticed?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below!
And if you enjoyed this video, then I really
appreciate a thumbs-up.
Tap left to watch my next Netflix video or
tap right for something else you're sure to
like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!